>>> THIS MORNING, DIFFERENT
VIEWS OF ONE CONVERSATION.
THE TWO-HOUR-PLUS PHONE CALL
BETWEEN PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
CHINESE LEADER XI JINPING,
ESPECIALLY OVER THE ISSUE OF
TAIWAN, IN THE MIDST OF A
POTENTIAL VISIT THERE BY HOUSE
SPEAKER, NANCY PELOSI.
THE STATEMENT FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE READS, QUOTE, ON TAIWAN,
PRESIDENT BIDEN UNDERSCORED THAT
THE UNITED STATES POLICY HAS NOT
CHANGED AND THE UNITED STATES
STRONGLY OPPOSES UNILATERAL
EFFORTS TO CHANGE THE STATUS QUO
OR UNDERMINE PEACE AND STABILITY
ACROSS THE TAIWAN STRAIGHT.
NOW, THE CHINESE READOUT IS
DIFFERENT.
THIS IS WHAT THE CHINESE SAY.
THEY SAY, WE FIRMLY OPPOSE
TAIWAN INDEPENDENT SEPARATISM
AND INTERFERENCE BY EXTERNAL
FORCES AND WILL NEVER LEAVE ANY
SPACE FOR TAIWAN INDEPENDENCE
FORCES OF ANY FORM, ADDING,
QUOTE, PUBLIC OPINION SHALL NOT
BE VIOLATED, AND IF YOU PLAY
WITH FIRE, YOU GET BURNED.
I HOPE THE U.S. SIDE CAN SEE
THIS CLEARLY.
THE U.S. SIDE SHOULD ABIDE BY
THE ONE CHINA PRINCIPLE AND
IMPLEMENT THE THREE CHINA U.S.
JOINT COMMUNIQUES.
SO CNN'S WILL RIPLEY IS IN
TAIWAN WITH THEIR REACTION TO
THE CURRENT TENSIONS.
>> Reporter: TAIWAN TRAINS FOR A
CHINESE ATTACK.
AIR RAID SIRENS IN TAIPEI.
FIGHTER JETS SCRAMBLE.
HELICOPTERS HUNT SUBMARINES.
DESTROYERS OPEN FIRE.
CHINA'S REFUSAL TO PUBLICLY
CONDEMN RUSSIA'S WAR ON UKRAINE,
ADDING URGENCY OF ISLAND'S
ANNUAL MILITARY DRILLS, FUELING
FEARS OF A CROSS-STRAIGHT
CONFLICT.
TAIWAN TENSIONS DOMINATED A MORE
THAN TWO-HOUR CALL THURSDAY.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN AND CHINESE
LEADER XI JINPING TRADE WARNINGS
ON TAIWAN.
CHINESE STATE MEDIA QUOTING XI.
THOSE WHO PLAY WITH FIRE WILL
PERISH BY IT.
THE OMINOUS WARNING AMID GROWING
SPECULATION U.S. HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI MAY BE PLANNING A
TRIP TO TAIWAN.
A PLAN DISCOURAGED BY BIDEN.
>> THE MILITARY THINKS IT'S NOT
A GOOD IDEA RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: PELOSI WON'T TALK
ABOUT HER TRAVEL PLANS FOR
SECURITY REASONS.
IT WOULD BE THE HIGHEST-LEVEL
U.S. VISIT IN 25 YEARS.
>> THERE COULD HAVE BEEN MORE
DIALOGUE BETWEEN TAIWAN AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
RATHER THAN HAVE THIS CONFUSING
MIXED SIGNALS PRESENTED OUT
THERE OPENLY IN THE PUBLIC, IN A
WAY THAT NOW CHINA HAS NOTICED
AND WILL RESPOND IN SOME WAY.
>> Reporter: A U.S. AIRCRAFT
CARRIER STRIKE GROUP IS BACK IN
THE SOUTH CHINA SEA, CITING
ROUTINE OPERATIONS AHEAD OF
PA
PELOSI'S POSSIBLE VISIT.
>> IT WOULD BE TAIWAN RIGHT
THERE NEXT TO CHINA.
>> Reporter: BEIJING PROMISES
FIRM AND RESOLUTE MEASURES TO
SAFEGUARD NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY.
CHINESE PASSPORTS SHOW TAIWAN AS
A MAINLAND PROVINCE, EVEN THOUGH
IT HAS ITS OWN MILITARY AND
GOVERNMENT FOR MORE THAN SEVEN
DECADES.
>> TAIWANESE IS A COUNTRY,
TAIWAN IS OUR HOME.
WE ARE NOT PART OF ANYONE.
NOT CHINESE, NOT AMERICANS.
>> Reporter: CHINA CONSIDERS
U.
U.S./DIPLOMACY A RED LINE.
BEIJING WON'T RULE OUT USING
FORCE.
>> WE WILL SHOW OUR WILLING TO
DEFEND OURSELF.
>> DEFENDING AGAINST CHINA'S
MASSIVE MILITARY WOULD BE A
HERCULEAN TASK.
TAIWAN IS COUNTING ON FRIENDS
LIKE THE U.S. TO DEFEND THEIR
DEMOCRACY FROM WHAT THEY CALL A
GROWING THREAT.
>> IN RECENT DAYS, CHINESE
DRONES HAVE BEEN CONDUCTING
SURVEILLANCE ON TAIWAN, AND EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE BRIEFED ON THAT
CALL BETWEEN XI AND BIDEN,
CERTAINLY, PUBLICLY, THEY ARE
SAYING THEY WELCOME NANCY
PELOSI, BUT THERE IS A DEBATE ON
THE GROUND ON WHETHER SUCH A
HIGH-PROFILE U.S. VISIT IS
HELPING OR HURTING TAIWAN'S
LONG-TERM POSITION WHEN IT COMES
TO THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA
AND TRYING TO KEEP THE PEACE,
JOHN.
>> WILL RIPLEY IN TAIPEI FOR US.
WILL, IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU